so I love your question solution number
one
is we need to build up stronger more
competent powerful men who are assertive
who have boundaries who are respectful
who are financially stable who are
physically fit who are emotionally
healthy who are spiritually grounded we
need well-rounded men who not only have
all the skills that make women happy but
also have all the skills to make a woman
horny we need those men not just these
you know these nice guy Weenie Hut
Juniors who are doormats shout out
SpongeBob
actually I've never I didn't know that
was from SpongeBob it was it was and we
don't also need these hyper masculine
bravado gaston-like characters we don't
need either or we need strong competent
capable men and we need to create
um places where those men where men can
come and get those resources that's why
I'm so passionate about the standard the
reality of the standards when men join
the standard they're around my life I
can't fake nothing I told the guys this
in December when I started I said yo if
I'm faking what I'm saying if I don't
live what I preach you guys will be
around shout out to J.R Garcia and the
Andres and the Ryan's and and all the
guys in the standard they know it they
know it they're around me all the time I
I can't am I faking it because I told
you if I'm fake they can expose me in a
minute because they're around me so my
biggest thing is that we need to go and
create communities where we're building
up men we're teaching them how to have
healthy marriages because marriage some
marriages do work do a lot a lot of them
unhappy yes but some some are happy
let's learn from them let's replicate
them let's learn from your parents let's
learn from my parents let's learn from
the people who are doing well and let's
teach the men how to do those things
let's also protect them and protect them
in if you're a guy who you have lots of
money let's protect them that's if your
guy you're worried about your children
losing custody let's protect them let's
teach strategies and techniques to
protect men as well as women because to
me the best advice benefits men and
benefits women I want you protected as
well I don't want you to be 45 years old
and all of a sudden your husband says
screw you I'm about to get a new woman
novice on your 45 or three three kids
and now you're like I want to go back in
the native market after I hit the the
wall I don't want to go back into the
mini market that's not fair we have to
protect you as well to want to protect
the men protect the women and on top of
that while we're building up stronger
men we got to build up healthy women
because my biggest pushback why I don't
like the showing the hoes on um your
show the the currency of today's is is
attention that is a currency if you ask
the 18 year old kid which would rather
have a million followers and a million
followers and a thousand dollars or a um
a thousand followers and a million
dollars well well a thousand in a minute
you asked the average 18 year old kid
today no I'm thinking like you'd have to
make the the money higher for it to be
comparable a million dollars yeah and a
thousand followers or a million
followers and a thousand sorry oh yeah
that I picked a million dollars 18 year
old kids know what the currency of today
is uh -huh followers yeah they want the
cloud they want that blue check they
want that followers on Tick Tock you
don't give a thing about the money
because they'll be like you know I'll
use my followers to get the money they
think to follow attention today is the
currency so my a lot of these women who
are doing this foolishness you know why
they're doing it because there's
attention there if there was no
attention they wouldn't do it if these
girls if they if they twerked on
Instagram and they got two followers and
they got three likes They're Gonna Stop
Twerking real goddamn quick and so my
biggest thing is that we need to stop
incentivizing their behavior we need to
stop celebrating these women's unhealthy
Behavior we need to stop showing them we
need to freaking give them no attention
you see what happens is and and it's
like La La Land to me that'll never
happen well and guess what no no not
also is La La Land the world that you're
describing as well because we because
you asked somebody 70 years ago could
the world ever get this bad they said it
would never get this way it would never
get this bad this will never happen but
guess what sometimes La La Land exists
and good and in bad so the same way same
way Society can go down unless you're
saying screw it and screw it I think in
the 70s they would have believed it what
you mean the free love [ __ ] they would
have believed it man that was some
hippies in California those are some
hippies in Woodstock they didn't think
that would go into New York City and
Alabama in Iowa in South Dakota and all
in Arkansas I didn't believe it was
gonna go all around the world like the
way it is going right now my point is
duh we need to stop it the people with
wisdom need to stop incentivizing those
women I never forget and I keep on going
back to it women women know I can go I
can go in your charm school I can act a
fool and guess what my only fans will go
up because I will get more followers the
more rude I go rude I am on your show on
Life Academy I'm the nasty B word I'ma
get more followers I'm gonna get more
guys subscribed to my only fans so their
incentivized to go on your show and act
a fool screw that you are not getting a
dollar a penny a cent from me I will
give you zero zero brand awareness I
will give you zero publicity because
we're not celebrating women like you
we're celebrating the positive women
that healthy women the women who want to
create lasting families women who
actually want to stay through thin and
thin through and Thin and Thick we want
to celebrate women like that that's the
solution emphasizing highlighting those
women and all women all the Instagram
followers why do they have millions of
followers why are men following those
women you're calling them three or fours
why are you following them why are you
on their page why are you liking them if
you if men simply said screw it i'm
we're done with the Instagram we're done
with the only things we're done with the
tick tock make it shut this whole thing
down they make their money from men men
are the leaders in society so to me we
either played a victim mindset and woe
with me the world's coming to an end and
screw it I'm just gonna go hide and
travel the world and bang random
unhealthy women or we can say you know
what Society is going to hell in the
handbasket but not during my lifetime
during my lifetime while I'm here I'm
gonna do every freaking thing in my
power to stop this fools from going down
even if things are not creating a
lasting change it will this the ship
will not go down on my watch
just interesting you have all this like
men should be more but like I I didn't
really hear much that the women need to
do what did I tell you at the very you
weren't even listening what did I tell
you you said we need to it I said women
such as yourself have the most power you
know why because you have the ability to
create healthier women women you're a
woman they will be able to listen to you
once you get the credibility once you
get your tone once you get your approach
I can't create wife Academy that idea
had years ago I couldn't create it I
must a man telling women how to be a
wife no they're not gonna listen why not
like Kevin Samuels did let me tell you
something it's like I would say his
audience was like 40 women which is
really mad in the manosphere let me tell
you something and look up school of
affluence when you get the chance she is
what I she does a little bit differently
but she has like a 90 female audience
but she's a little bit different she's
not she doesn't have the values that you
and I may have but she's teaching women
how to be the women that the kind of man
that she goes after wants and she has a
huge audience for it so my biggest thing
is God rested the dead nothing but great
things I will always say publicly
nothing but great things about the
Godfather himself Kevin Samuels my
biggest thing is I don't want 40. I want
you to get 80 90 of women I want you to
be and women like yourself to be able to
help a next generation of women and we
are doing it with the standard a lot of
women come to our events a lot of really
healthy women are being tapped into the
community could have seen while those
guys were over there those guys are
being settled because what happens is
like you said the women want the
attention from the men if the men are
like we don't want only fans no we don't
want PornHub no we don't want that no
some of the women will get in line well
most of them get in line it doesn't
matter we want someone to get in line
and then we then you factor that into
the equation women such as yourself and
other common creators like you who are
now creating a healthier better
generation of women not worried about
those 304s and just simply trying to
make mindless content but actually
taking the women who want to learn
giving them the tools to be successful
that truly to me will create the change
in society but I just think like 40 I
mean I think we just see it in a
different way like I think 40 of like
Millions is better than 90 of a thousand
and a big pull up your phone right now
type in anime tell me how many followers
she has so um this phone you can do it
on your phone because this phone died
this is my UK phone so like it actually
doesn't this phone died I'm gonna pull
up Anna base YouTube channel
okay okay let's let's put Annabelle's
YouTube channel dude would you say she
had the same poll like Kevin Samuels
Andrew Tate any of them okay how many
family followers does she have uh 1.39
million go to our videos and see her
videos as well uh-huh go ahead dude yeah
can my point is that the wind is do you
think she'd do wife School
trust me she's doing wife School her way
that's what I'm telling you she's doing
but she's High Society
for like an episode no trust me her you
you have to pay a lot of money she's
yeah we do yeah no trust me I know how
much money you make you guys are doing
well so
trust me I understand people tell me a
lot of things I I know I've been around
the block I meet a lot of different
people I know you're doing well my plan
the reason why I brought up Anna Bay is
because she's doing very very very
high-end things and she's and obviously
she's she's in Europe as well which
might work a little bit better for you
at least she's in Sweden by the way and
so my point with her is that she
actually has a community of women she's
able to talk directly to women and to be
able to influence and change women's
lives and so to me that is what it's
about we need women doing this I just
cannot argue that she has the same reach
as someone like Kevin Samuels and that's
what I'm saying like like 40 of a
million is better than than you know 90
of a thousand and I don't like I know
she's got 1.4 but I'm saying like Kevin
was bigger like everyone knew who he was
here's here's a reality similar to you
and I yeah you we are both forgetting
two fundamental things like I said I
don't wanna I don't like talking about
individual people Kevin is not here the
only reason I'm just using it as an
example like that's the only reason
here's what I'm saying shout out to
Kevin Samuels Kevin Samuels he would do
a lot of things in person he had to stop
because of um of covet but my biggest
thing is that the the reach is great God
bless the reach but what's really most
impactful which which what takes the
most time is to invest your time and
energy into actually being with the
individuals like events you're talking
about yeah events meetups it takes that
takes time you can't record seven days a
week if you're doing meetups and doing
the best and traveling around the world
actually because we're trying to set the
yeah I know I know that so to me it goes
back to what maximum and maximum
exposure or Maximum Impact there's a
balancing act and the and the more you
want to have an impact the less of
exposure you're going to have because
impact happens right here face to face
one-on-one person to person you can't
only do so much of that and so my
biggest thing is the Maximum Impact I
believe women's yourself can do is
actually one being the things that
you're telling women that they need to
be to start off with yourself so if
you're like you know what women should
get married they should be this Saturday
you need to be that needs to be probably
number one on your list and then once
you're able to do do that yourself
you'll be able to then help other women
get there as well that to me is a change
because my desire is that a 17 year old
woman can say you know what I can either
be that Instagram model have millions of
subscribers have millions of dollars but
no husband no children living a
depressed life or I can be just pearly
things have a beautiful husband have a
beautiful children have a beautiful life
also have the millions of dollars and
subscribers and do it the right way when
we're able to show a society that there
is an alternative because what's
happening today's world is that the
alternative is not more sexual than the
other thing I want to lift up the
alternative that's why I'm so passionate
about creating lasting and real change
in this world and women like you like I
said previously I can't do it you guys
got to do it as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible